Hello Freak bitches.
And then you've been there back and
forth ever since.
Yeah.
The the first time I would say it wasn't
until my flight back that I felt that
initial like I gotta do something
because whenever I was there,
the problem just seems so huge.
And so I mean,
so insurmountable that what am I going
to do?
How am I going to help?
Um,
and,
and am I going to get endanger myself or
get sick or die or whatever in the
process.
Um,
and but on the way back I just felt
like,
you know,
if,
if not me then,
then who,
you know,
like they asked me if I would give them
a voice if I can help them,
if I could.
Um,
and I just felt,
I dunno,
a yearning,
a longing that I had to do something.
And,
uh,
so the,
the second trip back,
um,
was,
was great.
I got to actually meet some people that
really had some real plans.
Cause the first time I went with people
that we didn't have plans to actually
help or anything.
Um,
like sustainability was just kind of a
learning trip going and seeing what the
problems were.
Second time it was the university,
their uh,
their school of community development
and they had dreams of,
of giving them water,
given them land,
giving them food,
but they didn't have any way to do it
really.
They had the plan and everything in
place,
but they didn't have funding behind it.
They didn't have the technology behind
it.
Um,
and so the third time was whenever I
came back and I had studied how to build
those eco domes and I partnered with an
organization,
it's a great organization called water
for and they,
um,
they're big thing is what,
what I was searching for was how to put
the,
the tools are basically the power in the
hands of the people there instead of
having to have outside help,
how can we actually help them to
continue to do it,
continue the process.
And so water four puts the tools in the
people's hands and then they teach them
how to do it and then now they can do it
for themselves.
It can be a sustainable business forum.
They can,
they can use whatever model they want.
If it's a nonprofit model,
if it's a business model,
um,
to,
to make it sustainable there so that way
yet where I'm at,
Congolese can help Congolese in that
way.
I can hopefully,
you know,
fan the flame,
go over there to teach a more,
bring over the right people water if
we're really supported and sent over.
Um,
you know,
their director of implementation to come
really sit down with us for two weeks,
teach us,
he came back out,
did it again.
Now he's gone over since I've been back
already,
he's been back over teaching her team
and more,
you know,
strategies of how to dig these water
wells
and I wished it,
there was one parent that I could just
be like,
they're the good one and the other one's
bad,
right.
My mom would like throw hot water and my
pops and I'd be like,
what the fuck is going on?
And then,
you know,
he would do his team,
I smack or whatever.
And then she tried to punch him and then
he'd hit her and I was just like,
this is wwf in the crib.
I got a friend who still fights with his
wife and his wife threw a fucking
screwdriver at him and stuck him in the
arm,
like it's stuck out of his arm and he
fucked her that night.
He goes,
that shit turns me on.
I go,
what?
And he goes,
one time,
man,
it will,
this is hilarious.
They were watching a movie together and
uh,
she fell asleep at the movie.
So he took his pants down and it was
there watching 300.
He took his pants down and put his ass
hole like an inch away from her head and
goes,
and he yelled something.
She woke up and he farted right in her
face.
That's a new move.
That's the cornholio.
Oh man,
that's fucking went crazy.
She punched him in the mouth.
She fucking freaky.
She goes,
he goes,
she fucking made me see stars.
Like,
she cracked me in the job and he goes,
I fucking love it.
That shit turns me off.
It that turns you on.
I know,
man.
When I saw this stuff with my parents,
I was just say,
I never want to be in a family like
this.
Exactly.
I've always just dated.
Just Nice,
good people.
That's what I like.
I like,
I like people that are nice gear.
Sweet.
You don't want no yelling.
No,
not in the island.
No.
I don't want to yell at my friends.
I don't want anybody yelling at me.
That's the one thing I look for.
People ask,
what do you look for when you hire
people?
Good.
Trustworthy people.
Good values.
That's it.
You can't,
you can't teach that.
People have it or they don't.
Yeah.
I never,
he,
he actually,
the reason he got into it and to give
him go more in depth thought it was,
he embezzled,
uh,
I think $2 million from Ricoh cameras.
She's crying.
He was the cfo of Ricoh cameras
and he's a millionaire.
He was making,
you know,
in like the mid eighties,
he was making like six,
$700,000 a year,
which is like now it's way more.
Um,
and she was a million and a half now,
right?
Yeah.
He was making a lot of money back then.
We would take limos to Atlantic city
every weekend.
Whoa.
And then as the story goes,
he was just for two years,
I think,
just embezzling money.
He was just like doing shady
transactions and taking money off the
top.
And then he got caught when there was a
new CEO and he blackmailed the CEO
because he had information on the
company that they didn't want coming
out.
And he got out,
but he could never work in the industry
again.
So he became a gambler.
I mean a bookie and a gambler.
That's crazy.
So He's,
he embezzled $2 million.
Scottfree scottfree yeah.
Wow.
What a,
they were bringing up.
Yeah.
They were starting to get charges
together and he was facing like 40 life,
almost life in prison.
He loves the craziest fucking stressful.
Yeah.
And then he,
you know,
he became a gambler and this was around
the time my mom left him was like 86,
um,
he bet $300,000 on the red sox to win
the world series in [inaudible] 86.
Oh my goodness.
In the world series.
You remember that?
It was a good buck.
Yeah.
Oh No.
And he lost 300,000,
which was like most of their savings and
my mom left him the next day.
Jesus Christ.
Man Does that crazy.
No wonder why you're a comic.
I'm like,
no wonder.
I thought it was so cool man.
When I,
when I got involved in it,
it was like the Sopranos was on TV.
It was like my dad's a gangster,
but he was,
he was this like fat Jewish guy.
Like he wasn't,
he wasn't involved in any of that.
Like he knew guys that were like strong
men for the,
for the guy,
for,
you know,
really connected.
What did he die from?
Colon cancer.
It's probably a lot of it due to stress
right now.
He was,
he treated his body like crap.
He basically didn't exist for the last
10 years of his life.
He didn't pay taxes.
He wasn't on the map.
He didn't have id,
and he was just like,
totally.
He kept going.
He didn't have a bank account,
50,000 in cash above his bed on a
headboard,
witness protection program styles that
what was going on?
No,
he just didn't want to pay taxes.
He didn't want to pay taxes on any of
his money.
So like exist.
Really.
So did he know that he was at health
insurance?
So he didn't have any of that stuff and
he didn't take care of his body.
And then he got sick and it was already
like stage four,
stage five.
So he didn't know he was sick and just
decided,
fuck it.
I'm not going to pay taxes.
I'm just going to ride this out.
This was,
I mean,
he didn't pay taxes,
I think for around 15 years.
He didn't pay taxes.
Yeah,
he didn't exist.
He didn't have a driver's license.
He faked a driver's license.
You gotta fake id?
I do.
You should use a great dad.
He was like,
oh,
really?
[inaudible]
yeah.